atlantes welcome our next speaker Ernest
Frankel who will talk about system
biology their computer science
engineering and biology meet
hi so as Monty Python likes to say now
for something completely different I'm
gonna talk to you about biology not
computer science but I'm going to show
you how the algorithm is of the type
that being developed here at MSR have
really had the potential and the effect
of having a big impact and how we
understand biology but for those of you
from the math or computer science
background I might have called this talk
biology looks hopelessly complex it's
gonna get worse before it gets better
and you'll see what I mean let's let's
start with what apparently is a simple
disease it's a disease called
Huntington's and you don't have to be a
neurobiologist to be able to tell the
difference between the brain of a
patient who does not suffer from
Huntington's on the right and the brain
of the patient with Huntington's on the
left tremendous loss of brain structure
there now the origin of the disease the
mutation in a single gene and so you
would think that this would be case
where we could really understand how
mutations cause disease and therefore be
able to figure out how to cure disease
but this mutation has been known for
approximately twenty years and it's led
to no effective cure and certainly a no
effective cure but not even infective
treatment that's because the effective
biological molecules exist extremely
complex a single gene when mutated
affects lots and lots of biological
processes and the traditional approach
is the studying these diseases are not
getting us the kinds of answers that we
need and so in systems biology what
we're trying to do is make a whole
series of very systematic measurements
of what goes on in the cell pretty much
any property we can effectively measure
we want to measure and then use compute
a computational approaches to build up
relatively coherent views of what all
those data mean and allow us understand
how signals transfer through different
parts of the cell and where we might be
able to go and intervene and cure
diseases what things can we measure well
since the genomic revolution now that we
can measure sequence lots and lots of
genes we can measure the expression of
lots of different genes in an organism
we can measure lots of things about
proteins we can measure lots of things
about metabolites and we can try to
collect all of these different data
together and so these different genomic
proteomic omics technologies have the
benefit of being comprehensive but they
also have some severe severe
deficiencies when we look at multiple
different kinds of data
apply to the same problem well what we
typically find is that they don't tend
to tell us the same story so
here we've got a sort of yellow data and
blue data and green data representing
different technologies is applied to the
same biological problem and you see the
Venn diagram doesn't overlap very much
and that's a difficult problem when
we're trying to understand what's going
on we also have a lot of false positives
and false negatives in these data what
we try to do in this Omega approach is
to try to understand how all of these
data could really arise from a single
biological process and so in this
cartoon you've got some cell surface
receptor on the outside of cell
detecting its environment and it sends
information into the cell and talks to
lots of different proteins and then
those proteins can send information down
into the nucleus where it can change
gene expression and we might find you
know the the blue technology tells
mostly about one kind of protein one
kind of process and the yellow
technology tells us more about another
kind of process but there is some
underlying physical reality and so we're
going to turn to algorithmic approaches
particularly graph theory to see if we
can discover what those apropos
commonalities are what the underlying
biological process is that gave rise to
these apparently
disparate data but the problem this is
where the gets worse before it gets
better is that when we try to do that we
end up with these network structures
that are just too complex for human
beings to understand and so we need to
come up with algorithms that allow us to
find the interesting part of all these
many interactions among hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of different
proteins and genes and so what we've
done is turned to a class of algorithms
called prize collecting Steiner trees
and in this approach we have nodes and
edges the nodes represent either
proteins or genes and the upper at the
edges represent potential interactions
among these proteins or genes physical
interactions and then we try to find a
subset of the data from say the genes
and proteins that we think are changing
in the disease state indicated by the
color the yellow and the green that are
connected to each other possibly
directly but possibly through these
hidden nodes proteins and genes that we
didn't measure in our experiments
because their experiments aren't perfect
but are never less important for the
disease process and so when we apply
this prize collecting Steiner tree
algorithm it takes that very complicated
graph and finds a sub graph that's most
important for the biological in problem
of interest and the algorithm can try to
decide whether some data point which so
relies on the edge our graph is so
relevant that it has included or whether
it's likely to be a false positive and
should be excluded now when we do this
on real biological data then we can get
insights into what the context are of
the genes that we detect is being
relevant to the disease so here we've
got a bunch of yellow proteins that are
functioning in similar process and we
can then learn what kinds of processes
are going on and we can also find nodes
in these networks that are very central
and might be places where drugs could be
used to target this altered process and
restore health to the organism so an
example where we've actually started to
apply this it's something called
glioblastoma it's very devastating brain
tumor it's usually diagnosed at a late
stage the only treatment really is
surgery combined with chemotherapy
without it patients survive very very
short times with this treatment they
survive usually a year or less so the
treatment is obviously not very good so
we've taken a model of this disease
where we have one gene that's been
mutated that's very common mutation in
the glioblastoma and we're looking at
the effect of that gene on the rest of
the cell we've collected all these
different omics kinds of technologies
and we've built a graph from those data
and in this graph the red nodes are ones
where there's experimental data and then
the circles that don't have color in
them are ones that the algorithm is
telling us are most are also relevant to
the disease and when we look at this we
immediately can decompose into sub
graphs that tell us a lot about the
biological processes involved some of
those are ones that are rich in red
those are ones where there's a lot of
experimental data and some of them have
a lot of clear circles those are ones
where the algorithm is telling us that
they're relevant to the disease process
but the experimental data by itself
would not have led us in those places
and so I can lead us some new hypotheses
as to what to look at and the other
thing that's extremely exciting about
this is now we can find potential new
drug targets and we can do that by
looking for the nodes in this network
that are most central so the single most
central node in this particular network
is a protein called sark and actually
it's been shown that if you target sark
and the mutation that is is affecting
these particular cells so the EGF
receptor mutation those two mutations
I'm sorry targeting those two proteins
simultaneously has a very strong effect
on blocking the growth of these tumor
cells and so that is a potential for a
combinatorial therapy to be much better
than individual treatments one and the
after the other
and now we can start working our way
down this list of both central nodes and
do experiments so this was an expected
result our next of most central node was
something was very surprising to us it's
a gene that doesn't seem to have any
known biology associating it with
glioblastoma but we can actually go into
the laboratory now and test whether
treating that node with the drug has an
effect in the growth of these tumor
cells and sure enough we can stop growth
of these tumor cells with that and if we
combine that treating that node with the
most the node at the top of the network
we actually get more than an additive
effect on blocking the growth of these
tumor cells and so what I hope I've been
able to give you a taste of is that we
can take these incredibly complicated
biological problems where we don't know
how to come up with treatment and do
very systematic measurements through all
these different kinds of omics
technologies and then apply the kinds of
algorithms developed here at MSR to
really develop models that allow us to
directly go and decide what to test
experimentally and hopefully lead us to
new ways of treating disease the work
that I described to you is largely done
by the three women on the top left Carol
Huang sta girl Odom in la riva in my
laboratory with a lot of wonderful
collaborations from people out of mighty
shown on that side of the graph and an
MS are here as well thank you very much
okay thank you honest for the wonderful
talk and we have time for questionnaire
encourage people to please go to the
microphone unless you have a one-word
question you can shout because if he has
to repeat three sentences it takes a
while nobody can you tell us what the
special protein you found was yeah so
when when Carol first showed me the
results of this computation I told her
oh this doesn't look too good because
the second most central note there is
the estrogen receptor which I'm sure
most of you know about estrogens being a
female hormone and it has no obvious
relationship to brain tumors but
actually turns out that glioblastoma is
much more common in men than women and
so we had a little bit of hope that
maybe this wouldn't turn out to be a
total red herring and sure enough our
experiments in laboratory seemed to be
confirming that at least in this cell
culture model of what's going on we can
block the growth of these tumor cells
and maybe someday it'll lead to an
effective treatment as well yeah so you
said that things are gonna get much more
complex before they're gonna get it
simple I'm wondering if there's a sort
of a middle ground possible where you
use very complex algorithms come up with
a hypothesis which may even surprise
everyone but then once you have the
hypothesis there are simpler algorithms
to confirm the very validity I mean how
much can you trust this very very
complex algorithm and its output that's
that's a great question and I don't
think we can trust it in the sense of
100% confidence what the goal of this is
from my perspectives is leading us to do
better experiments so if we start with
the whole human genome the whole human
proteome we have too many possible
things to test we can't we can't explore
all the possibilities by using these
algorithms we can focus in on the parts
of the the proteome where we could
actually try to do experiments and if we
are success rate is one in ten that's
still better than one in 20,000 okay so
that's all I'm sure Shaw to your
question has to be one name one word
though right
what diseases do we focus on and what do
we do with these targets when we find
them so we've been focusing a number of
different diseases some of them are
chosen because they're devastating and
anything we can make progress on would
make a big difference so Huntington is
something we work on our lab Global
awesome I've told you about some of them
are extremely common ones like a type 2
diabetes which is becoming much more
common in the developed world with
increasing obesity and these are
diseases where people have tried to do
all the obvious experiments so taking a
completely unbiased view might lead us
in very different directions and
potentially have a very big payoff what
do we do with the results well the
primary thing we do with them is try to
get them out there to a larger community
to community so we do some experiments
in our laboratory to test and try to
find the most most plausible things but
then the goal is to really expand this
knowledge and send it out to other
people can confirm in other models of
diseases and then hopefully the
pharmaceutical industry pick it up as
well okay let's thank analysts again
okay